hi there I'm Daniel Dwyer welcome to the
point now as you know video games are
made up of digital experiences
experiences like playing sports driving
cars shooting your friends and exploring
virtual worlds but these systems are
made up of mechanics that play with our
sense of challenge and achievement they
can't always see these mechanics but
their power is very real alright take
this shell game underneath one of these
cups is a ball all right pick one now I
could let you know which one it is but
this is actually the best part of the
game for you the player right now you
feel empowered you think that you
actually still might win so what if I
kept giving you this feeling over and
over again or what if I showed you and I
let you win and various intervals you'd
probably like that quite a lot at least
that's what behavioral science tells us
and they also tell us that you'd
especially like it if we accompanied
that victory with a lot of flashing
lights and celebratory music ten years
ago one of the best and most addictive
video games ever made was released by
Blizzard Entertainment a game that's had
an active player base over ten million
five high selling expansion packs and
remains a lucrative cash carry over
Blizzard or rather Activision Blizzard
now world of warcraft was a
subscription-based game so they had to
convince you to pony up the $9.99 a
month with satisfying stuff to do and
that game had a bunch of satisfying
stuff to do a ridiculously large
connected open-world multiple races with
multiple classes that could be SPECT in
different ways
hundreds of quests ways to play
creatures to kill and places to explore
when the first expansion pack came along
had added two new races flying mounts a
higher level cop and an entire new
planet with countless quest cities
dungeons raids and enemies to enjoy this
expansion the Burning Crusade cost $40
and came out over two years after the
original game by the time Activision's
console cash-cow destiny has been add
for a year and finally pumped full of
enough content to warrant at $60 asking
price they would have sold a vast
majority of users and additional $80
worth of expansions so for many that's a
total of 140 dollars for one year of
destiny
and what's brilliant about this is that
if you've sunk over 200 hours in the
destiny
that probably seems like a pretty great
value proposition destiny has no monthly
fee it's been designed not to require it
it's a game with a user base famished
for new stuff to do so when there is new
content not only is everyone excited to
get access to it but they're willing to
pay for it because [__] it the shooting
in this game is actually brilliant
you've got hundreds of hours of
entertainment from this game and all
your online buddies are probably gonna
buy the content anyway right look I'm
not here to [__] on destiny players
cereal believe me there's no doubt that
the game is a quality online co-op
shooter but what does disturb me is that
this game has clearly been made to make
Activision quite a lot of money and
they're using behavioral science
techniques used in casinos to get people
hooked as a means of doing so which one
was it you picked again
the point season 3 episode 16 destiny
the hardcore gamer slot machine in 2011
a man named John Hobson wrote an article
on Gamasutra entitled behavioral game
design it's a wonderful read I encourage
you all to take a look at it yourself in
this he details ways in which players
react to ratios and intervals
that's the likelihood of being rewarded
with bonuses in a game the intervals
between said rewards and how finally
balancing these can create addictive
gameplay behavioral science is an
important part of many industries most
often used in these super-fun fields of
advertising marketing and the gambling
industry it can be the difference
between creating a system that you put
down after a few minutes hours or days
or weeks and when you engage with four
months or maybe years certain reward
ratios and games are set we all know if
you collect 100 coins Mario gets a new
life we know unlocking the best gear and
call of duty comes after X amount of
kills with the shitty guns some of these
rewards ratios work and others don't
titanfall is a good example of how it
might not there's no doubt it was a
great game but the player base dropped
off really soon after the first month
because there was never that Chase to
unlock better gear most of the good
stuff was easily attainable and all the
extra DLC levels in the world can't help
a game if players feel like they have
nothing to grind towards but what if the
player never knew when the next unlock
was coming what effect would that have
John explains the best when he
references BF Skinner's operant
conditioning experiments in which they
manage to replicate the behaviors of
humans using slot machines in a casino
with pigeons looking
not just by giving them rewards but by
varying when the rewards are given the
main thing is what's what we call
schedules of reinforcement reinforcement
they been called award and you can
schedule it so that a reward occurs
every now and then when a pigeon does
something we usually use a response with
pigeon pecking a little disk spot in the
wall and you can reinforce with food but
you don't reinforce every time you're
every perhaps early tense time or
perhaps only once every minute or
something like that there are very large
number of schedules one of the one of
the schedules is very effective with the
wrathful pigeons is what we call the
variable ratio schedule and that is at
the heart of all gambling devices and
has the same effect people gamble
because of the schedule reinforcement
follows and this is all gambling says
they all have variable rachels built
into them so what we've learned from the
pigeon it made it possible to interpret
this fast filled very effectively like
Diablo or raiding and Wow variable
ratios are core to destinies addictive
quality if the player doesn't know
exactly when the reward is coming then
it could arrive at any time
I kind of remember many moments from my
time playing World of Warcraft but I
still remember the day I got an epic
drop from a random Raptor in
stranglethorn fail every time I killed a
random mob after that a little part of
me wondered if I might get another epic
it was like scratching a lottery ticket
or pulling a one-armed bandit that's
because the variable ratio schedule is
the same technique used on millions of
computerized slot machines around the
world and the more of these mechanisms
you have working at any one time the
less chancellor is the player to get
bored in those intervals in destiny
you're always looking for that next big
drop sometimes it's at a fixed ratio
that you could aim for like say a weapon
from a pass or something you can buy
with glimmer you grind it for sometimes
it's variable a random drop from an
enemy and then there are marks Vanguard
and crucible marks that you get from
strikes or the PvP stuff but you only
get a hundred of these a week so you
kind of have to come back and grind for
those at a different time and then
there's the wrap with the various
factions who won't sell you stuff unless
you are cool with them oh and don't
worry if any of that stuff isn't working
out right now you're probably grinding
your character level at the same
- it's an ever-shifting morphing system
where old units of exchange become
redundant and content updates bring new
currencies new ways to win new ratios
with overlapping intervals so you're
always stuck in some sort of feedback
loop
you're always achieving oh sorry you
getting bored no no no don't get bored
here's an Engram take it to a vendor
he'll unlock it for you that's called
delayed gratification in fact Scientific
American mind just published an article
about delayed gratification this month
in which they explained how it increases
the value of an anticipated reward
regardless of its actual contents so
your brain will really enjoy the
dopamine hit this little thing gives you
even when you bring it to the vendor and
it ends up being another piece of [__]
green rocket launcher it's a game full
of these tiny little tricks to please
your brain that's why it's so
restrictive that's why they don't allow
you to trade items if they allow that
you'd avoid too many of the little
pleasing brain tricks they've stuck in
there remember our friend John he spent
years working on Microsoft on games like
Halo 2 and Age of Empires 3 his role was
to conduct research into this player
satisfaction proposing gameplay ideas
that would eventually lead to higher
player satisfaction and an increase in
total playing time while I brought up
his expertise for a reason it turns out
Jon now works for bungie as lead of both
their customer relationship management
and user research teams this is a team
of researchers who provide our designers
with feedback from real gamers and then
help them use that feedback to inform
better design decisions which includes a
wide variety of research activities
ranging from small-scale lab studies to
betas and analytics for millions of
players
now I can hear the appeals already yes
all games have mechanics to keep you
cops they want you to keep playing to
keep being entertained at least usually
until the story culminates designers
want to keep you engaged entertained but
most games of the contents to keep this
loop going until its eventual end
destiny doesn't and I'm beginning to
think it's by design destiny is a
Content pipeline which has been made
with the goal of creating users hungry
for new content all the new content
comes in the form of paid expansion
packs and there are lots of them with
other games season passes and DLC
content appeals to players who want to
play more more Maps more modes more
skins and over the past few years we've
seen more developers and publishers take
more out of their games in order to sell
them to us later destiny has taken us to
a whole new level in that their DLC
their season pass is content practically
every player of the game wants we all
raise our pitchforks at the idea of
optional content with the content parks
and deaths and they aren't really
optional they are essential to it being
a game worth playing
remember this is Activision's 10-year
project a 500 million dollar investment
which their shareholders will respect a
return on this is a game with millions
of registered players that in the first
year so three expansion sets I will have
netted them one hundred and forty
dollars from most of their customers
this is why I take exception with
destiny I'm not saying it's a bad game
I'm saying it's a manipulative one I
mean it's farmville for shooter fans
just instead of farming the land you're
farming XP loot and whatever fake new
currency the game creates to keep you
inside another masterfully crafted ratio
scheduling system look I don't like
[__] on games for the sake of it
destiny is a good game maybe it's a
great game a lot of people here at
GameSpot love it in fact this probably a
bunch of people upstairs playing it
right now but what I am doing is
highlighting what I genuinely believe
are distasteful game design practices
this game is managed to sell a lot of
DLC and the back of using techniques
we've learned from
pigeons and people using one-armed
bandits in casinos and if that doesn't
make me feel uncomfortable certainly as
somebody involved in the games price
that I don't know what really can
destiny is a game that has been crafted
to get people coming back if you want to
play for an hour there's something to do
if you want to play for the whole
weekend there's something to do don't
worry there user research team has you
covered with a variety of ways to keep
you happy Hey
people are free to do whatever they want
to entertain themselves games are a
release there are entertainment and sure
on the face of it $100 maybe over a
course of a year let's say 10 bucks a
month if you play this game a lot it's
probably a good return on investment but
when these sorts of behavioral practices
are being used to encourage people into
spending hard-earned cash on content
that they rightfully should have gotten
in the game at release or at the very
least free as an apology I can't agree
that that's okay I don't want this to
work I've nothing against Bungie or
Activision but there's enough of this
skeezy psychological game design
[__] happening in the world of
Facebook games and mobile games that
edit being dragged into our playpen if
this is the future of triple-a
development and I worry for the future
of triple-a development in any case I'm
choosing not to indulge this type of
game design practices and that really is
of my own free will
oh and as for the shell game well
actually this was a con job used by
street artists to swindle people out of
their hard-earned cash but you know as
you paid all the DLC and I probably want
to keep you as a happy customer
congratulations you win
[Music]
let's play again where does that leave
free will because we all can have a
choice when to do things are not to do
yes
when you see we assumed somehow or other
that these internal states feelings and
so on have initiated something they have
started something they have created we
have done something in about in a
voluntary way we have willed to act if
you now look at the actual history we
find that there are external reasons why
this has happened in other words by
discovering the causes of behavior we
can dispose of the imagined internal
cause we dispose of freewill as an
American divine of the 18th century
Jonathan Edwards did he said we believe
in free will because we know about our
behavior but not about its causes and of
course it societies it's the object of
the science of able to discover causes
and once you have found those causes
there is less we need to attribute to an
internal act to will and eventually I
think we did you achieve it nothing to
it
[Music]
you